acht Monate Krieg in der Ukraine und wir
wollen anfangen mit ganz aktuellen
Bildern von heute morgen dieses
flammende Inferno hier ist die Szene die
sich heute Nacht in der Stadt
schachtarsk im Osten der Ukraine
abgespielt hat und das ist nicht
irgendein Feuer sondern was wir hier
sehen ist ein treibstoffzug ein Zug
voller Benzin der gestern Abend aus
Russland in die Ostukraine die besetzte
Ost Ukraine eingefahren ist und heute
Nacht aber dann von der Ukraine dort
angegriffen wurde und wir sehen das
vielleicht ein wirkliches Inferno viele
der Waggons die hier eben mit Treibstoff
Richtung Front fahren wollten wurden
dort zerstört wir sehen uns gleich noch
mal in einer anderen Perspektive und
hier ihr könnt das einfach mal kurz uns
ansehen das sind also die Waggons die
noch funktionieren wo noch kein Feuer
ausgebrochen ist und hier eben das
Inferno von dem wir gerade gesprochen
haben
russland hat versucht dort seine Panzer
seine Schützenpanzer seine
Raketensysteme mit Treibstoff
auszustatten das ist extrem wichtig um
eben weiter an der Front sich zu bewegen
aber die Ukraine hat diesen
treibstoffzug hier etwa 60 Kilometer von
der Front entfernt angegriffen und
dieser Angriff und der Ort des Angriffs
verraten uns auch etwas über die
genutzten Waffen Schacht Task liegt etwa
hier also wirklich an der Grenze
zwischen den echten Russland und den
besetzten Teilen der Ostukraine und wie
gesagt etwa 60 Kilometer zur Front das
heißt das System was dort genutzt wurde
um diesen Konvoi anzugreifen muss
mindestens 70 bis 80 km von der Front
entfernt gewesen sein und das war aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach dem nach eine
ein amerikanisches heimat-system also
diese Gelenken Raketen die dort genutzt
wurden um eben diesen Konvoi anzugreifen
wir wollen es aber auch andere Szenen
aus dem Osten des Landes angucken und
wir gehen einfach mal in den Norden hier
nämlich in die Region luhans cluans dort
wo wir sehen das an dem blauen die
Ukraine weit vorgedrungen ist aber die
Russen eben auch alles tun um dort die
Front zu halten und diese Aufnahmen
zeigen uns einfach mal wie extrem dort
die Kämpfe sind also wie dort
tatsächlich Mann gegen Mann im
Infanterie also nicht über weiter
Entfernung große Panzer oder Raketen
sondern wirklich Mann gegen Mann mit
Gewehren gekämpft wird
und die Ukrainer sich versuchen
vorzuarbeiten dort für Dorf eben dort
vorzubringen und wir wissen ja dass
Russland 300.000 Mann gerade erst mobil
gemacht hat die gerade erst auch hierhin
entsendet wurden um die Front zu halten
und umso schwerer ist es eben für die
Ukrainer hier vorzudringen aber sie
haben erste Erfolge das sehen wir jetzt
das hier die absoluten zerstörte das
zerstörte Zentrum des dorfeske ein
strategisch wichtiges Dorf aus Russland
derzeit drei Wochen versucht hat mit
allen Kräften zu halten und wir sehen
jetzt hier wie die russische Flagge
abmontiert wird oder an Boden
geschmissen wird und stattdessen die
Ukraine nicht angebracht wird das also
nächste was gestern wohl befreit wurde
die Russen dementieren das noch und
sagen die Kämpfe gehen weiter aber die
Ukraine und wir sehen uns hier auch mit
mit Bildern unterwegs sagen dass dieses
Dorf befreit wurde zum Schluss wollen
wir uns noch einmal einer Stadt widmen
die etwas aus den Schlagzeilen gekommen
ist nämlich Mario Pohl hier unten wir
erinnern uns zwei Monate lang zwischen
März und und Mai sogar ging hier die
Kämpfe hat man versucht diese Stadt zu
merken und wir erinnern uns auch wie
dort diese riesigen Massengräber
ausgehoben wurden damals für eben
tausende Tote und wir gucken uns das
einfach mal an so sehen diese Bilder
heute aus so sehen die Gräber heute aus
und wir warten einfach mal bis die
Kamera sich genau eines dieser Gräber
anguckt da haben wir es nämlich das ist
das Grab mit der Zahl
2.818 und wenn wir uns ansehen was
bisher an russischen Kriegsverbrechen
eben aus dem Land kam ich erinnere an
Butcher wo etwa 800 Menschen getötet
wurden ich erinnere an ihren easium wo
man etwa 400 Körper gefunden hat und wir
sehen uns dieses Ausmaß hier mal ein
dass daneben das 2851 dann sehen wir das
hier tausende womöglich 10.000
Zivilisten während das russischen
Angriffes getötet wurden und dann eben
mit Massengräbern namenlosen massengrill
waren verscharrt wurden das also die
Situation im Südosten der Ukraine der
eben nicht befreit ist der weiter unter
russischer Kontrolle ist aber sollte er
eines Tages wieder zurück und der
ukrainische Kontrolle kommen und sollten
internationale ja
Untersuchungsbehörden von Menschen
Verletzung von Kriegsverbrechen dahin
kommen dann sieht man was dort für Gold
hatten Russlands eben gefunden werden
[Musik]